it just speaks to you in a different way
this is a piece of art
[Music]
this brings you back
to an era
where cameras were so unique in the way
they were used and designed in the build
quality this is an absolutely beautiful
camera it is one of the most beautiful
pieces of photography equipment i've
held in my hands over the past few years
this is one of the most beautiful
cameras i've ever held to date
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody what's going on so we are
in a very uh unique location today at
vicious cycles here in singapore because
we're going to talk about a camera that
i have been waiting
since it's been announced to get my
hands on it hasn't been easy to get our
hands on it in singapore but i finally
did of course is the 907x
cfv250c from hasselblad
uh
guys i mean i've talked about the x1d
the x1 d2 which are phenomenal cameras
the ergonomics the build quality the
image quality i mean it's some of the
best out there
but when this camera was announced
and i saw the images of it
i knew that this was going to be very
special
so
here we are today with the 907x and the
3575 3.5 to 4.5 xcd lens and we're going
to shoot inside this motorcycle shop
kind of take it through its paces and
have some fun along the way guys so
let's talk about
this camera
so by the way my motorcycle is actually
being built here as well we might see it
later on but anyway i don't want to go
through all the specs because there's
been plenty of videos on that but i'll
just highlight some of the key features
of course this is the same 50 megapixel
sensor medium format sensor that's in
the x1d and the x1 d2 has the same color
science the same speed the same
interface in terms of the user interface
of the camera but it's the the design of
this camera how it's like to hold and
use and the build quality and just how
unique this is
for a lot of modern day photographers
out there that
it just speaks to you in a different way
this is a piece of art
in my hands
this is one of the most beautiful
cameras i've ever held to date
and it takes phenomenal images so now
let's go inside the vicious cycles
let's take some photos of these iron
horses
with the 907x
man these are gonna be some beautiful
photos i can't wait
[Music]
all right guys so uh let's talk about
the design and build of course of the
907x now i'm just going to shorten the
name of this camera because it is quite
a lengthy name as i mentioned before
this is a stunning camera this brings
you back to the 500 series from
hasselblad the v series cameras but of
course they have modernized it but you
know the thing about this camera is is
that
no photo
or no video even as good as the video
exactly shooting right here is can
actually capture how beautiful this
thing is unless you pick it up in your
hands
the first time the chrome trimming
this leather or leatherette grain
texture that's around the camera
the attention to detail
everything screams quality there's
nothing that feels inexpensive or not
premium on this i mean hasselblad has
always been known to make beautiful
camera systems and they've really done
an amazing job now in terms of the
camera body itself it's very small very
compact okay this is a camera system
that
is meant for smaller lenses compact
travel walk around you can use this in
studio as well you can outfit it but you
will want to look at some accessories
because case in point there's only
literally two buttons on this camera to
use and a wheel and of course you have
your shutter release button here you
have a kind of a function or a command
button here that allows you to access
your exposure or various other controls
as you hold down and press this wheel
here you do have the touchscreen on the
back but we pretty much know that this
touch screen is intuitive it's user
friendly it's great just like the x1 d2
but this control grip here really does
make a big difference on the camera
system case in point it allows you to
actually actually activate auto exposure
lock and you can custom assign what in
the buttons to do that versus just
without it you can activate it on this
camera system now some people will use
this or they won't use it but if you
really want to get that great dynamic
range out of your image and get that
best the best optimal exposure sometimes
using spot metering with auto exposure
lock
does make a big difference in your
images and i'll show you some samples
later on when we do a lightroom portion
of this review but this control group
will be something that a lot of people
might want to have for this camera
reason being when you have a longer lens
like this 3575 or the 81.9 or we get
into the longer focal lengths there's
going to be a little bit of a weight
challenge with this camera because this
is very light on the back of it and yes
you can hold like this but this grip
does help in a lot of ways and it is
very ergonomical as other people have
talked about the shutter button is here
on the top which i wish it was here on
the uh towards the front it'd be much
easier if you want to shoot at various
different angles versus turning your
hand like this
something maybe hasselblad can improve
in the future but the overall look and
the build quality and the added
functionality to this does make this
camera a lot more user friendly now of
course this viewfinder with this 3575
zoom lens doesn't really help at all
this viewfinder is just more or less
there for aesthetics you can remove this
top piece and kind of use it as a cold
shoe but hasselblad doesn't recommend it
but i have seen other people use it that
way but it's quite expensive so i would
say err on the side of caution but yeah
definitely a highly recommended
accessory not cheap none of these
accessories are on this camera but again
we're not talking price when it comes to
this camera because we know if you're
watching this video already this is not
just a piece of equipment
an average piece of camera equipment
this is
art
this is a connoisseur's camera that
takes beautiful images now we're also
going to test how good this lens is
especially with metal objects chromatic
aberration and all that and i'll be
showing you some sample images in
lightroom later on in this review but
hasselblad tells us as the best lens
they've ever made and it's a zoom lens
and i can tell you right now
from the time i've had to review this
this is probably the best
performing zoom lens i've ever used in
terms of image quality
um this is a 3575 so in full frame
measurements it's about 28 50 plus
thereabouts it's just a stunning
stunning lens to use and the detail and
the depth that you're getting
is beautiful
so one of the great things about this uh
this control grip here is it allows you
to really uh move your auto focus point
around a little bit be more concise with
instead of using the touch screen
which
i really appreciate
because sometimes when you're into
longer lenses
it's a little challenging
to hold this here touch here and then go
back to your subject
can be done
but it
it's obviously better to just use this
thumb
this joystick here which is all
fantastic joystick very ergonomic
very easy to use
now in terms of speed of course
the x1d the x1 d2 and the 907x are not
going to be speed demons when it comes
to autofocusing it's still contrast
based
so if you're looking for a speed that's
going to be like a 1dx3 or an alpha one
or even let's say a gfx100s it's not
there yet this camera as other people
have said is really gonna slow you down
but that's not a bad thing actually
because
when you do get the shot in focus and it
locks on it's pin sharp those colors and
that image quality
literally just come alive
there's always been a lot of discussion
online of what camera is the better
color science
but uh
those who've tried hasselblad you know
you know what i'm talking about when i
say
the colors coming out of this
are beautiful and they're accurate which
is important because if you're going to
be doing a lot of product photography
or you want to be capturing something
for a client
you can't afford
can't afford for your product to be
miscolored or
you know spending hours on photoshop
or lightroom or capture one or even
focus tweaking those colors
now obviously in a shop like this you
know the light is controlled but of
course is a 3.5 to 4.5 lens so i am
going to have to crank up the iso quite
a bit so some of my shots will be around
3200 iso you're going to see that the
noise performance
is uh
really good for this camera system as a
matter of fact i push this up to about
12 000 or so and the images are
definitely usable so 3200 some
photographers say no they don't like
3200 but let me be honest with you
it's good clean up a little bit in post
and it is stunning
one of the reasons why i'm actually
taking a little bit longer to shoot than
just snapping photos i'm actually doing
spot metering with auto exposure lock to
really balance the exposure here in this
shot because with the chrome and with
the metal and just the reflections
coming out of this it's very easy to
over expose your shots so i tend to use
spot metering for this i find that it's
accurate odd exposure lock on more of a
brighter subject moving back to the
subject i want to shoot fire away and
most times are not
it's nice and balanced you see some rich
color coming out of it but exposure in
your image
correctly makes a world of difference
and it's something i learned from a
friend of mine peter chen who's a fine
art photographer which i'll be showing
some of his work later who shot with the
907x while we're walking around and i'll
show some of those images in lightroom
and it's a big lesson that i learned
shooting with this camera and it made a
world of difference in terms of how
the image rendered and the colors just
came alive so a little tip for you guys
on that
shoot in spot mode and uh yeah
auto exposure lock it does slow you down
a little bit
but
the end result is worth it
all right guys we're back in the home
studio let's take a look at images from
the hasselblad 907x plus the 3575 3.5 to
4.5 xcd lens
let's look at them now before i get into
images that i've taken at vicious cycles
i want to show you some images from my
friend peter chen as i mentioned earlier
in this review he was very kind enough
to loan me uh these images to show you
guys and this is from a walk that we did
together with the 907x he's never used
this camera before
he's used to using the old v series
hasselblad camera when he was doing
product photography um earlier in his
career so he was excited to try out this
907x so i said let's give it a shot and
these are some of the results
from one day actually one afternoon with
this camera
very very impressive and they're also a
very good testament to how good this
lens is case in point we were in the
central business district area in
singapore which is beautiful there's a
lot of you know high rises and in this
area there's a lot of blue towers that
are just it's really nice to see
but
i mean people could shoot buildings and
it can look plain or it can look very
interesting and i love how i love how
peter captured this case in point he
found this angle that you could see the
light and the dark to it and just this
depth to the buildings which was
beautiful to see but when we look at it
from a you know lens perspective look
how sharp it is here in the corners
all the way
to each corner here
to the center and he didn't do any
correction in terms of lens correction
in photoshop with this he just really
just tweaked the colors a little bit but
this is how it looks out of camera but
then he went to black and white
and black and white
adds a whole other dimension to it it is
absolutely beautiful
look at the tonality from the dark to
the light the graduation in the from the
you know
from the shadows to the exposed areas
it's just
something that medium format gives you i
mean you guys know this if you shoot
medium format i mean can you get some of
this from full frame
you can but it's not the same honestly
speaking yes 14 stops dynamic range you
can look at all the numbers it can be
very similar
to full frame
but when you see it up close you see
that the depth and the how organic the
image looks
it's what makes medium format so special
and of course it's a testament to this
lens how sharp it is there's no fringing
to this whatsoever the color
reproduction the sensor all of this
combined really makes for
beautiful images here's another shot of
this dbs tower here you can see the blue
reflections there and he preferred the
black and white and i do too because of
how dramatic it can look
but look at the tonality there and if we
just kind of you know punch in on this
you know how sharp it is give it a
second to render again these are about
300 megabyte images
and in
lightroom you know obviously it does
take a little bit of time
to uh pull up but we look at the image
as a whole how beautiful it looks i mean
unbelievable
um really really impressive i mean you
can just see the details in the windows
you can even see in some of the offices
there the lights they're showcasing
there it's really really something to
see but let's look at another image here
um from this shoot i did with a friend
of mine he has a mercedes sls beautiful
car
and uh this is the original image these
spots here are dust spots that were on
the sensor because the sensor can get
quite dirty if you remove the back off
and on so do take note of that get some
you know sensor cleaning uh products if
you have if you can get them
but uh unfortunately i didn't bring any
strobe light to this i was using natural
lighting the light was behind the car
so i really had to rely on the dynamic
range now the next image i'm going to
show you has been
it's been highly edited it's more
dramatic it might not be to your liking
but the owner of the vehicle wanted the
image to look this way so you know we do
what we're asked to do and here's the
end result so i did use a series of um
programs for this obviously lightroom
photoshop luminar ai
even focus for that matter to sort of do
the raw conversion initially um but yeah
it's
a little dramatic some people love it
but i wanted to give it that that uh
that pop and as you can tell just the
detail on there it still maintains of
course i uh
you know
what from the original to this
it's a testament to the dynamic range of
the sensor and again how good the lens
is because it is sharp to sharp it's
it's sharp corner to corner on this
really really impressive
so let's take a look at this image of
andre who owns painful industries inside
vicious cycles and he wanted a portrait
of himself but unfortunately i didn't
bring a strobe light again happens to me
quite a bit but we're in a motorcycle
shop i don't want to bring a lot of
equipment in there's a lot of things
that can you know mess things up so i
was using the lighting sources that were
available to me and there was two
polarizing lighting sources on one side
there's this bright white it almost has
a bluish
tint to it then on the other side this
really warm orange light and i'm trying
to balance in between them and i try to
do the best as i could and i'll show you
what i'm talking about here is the
original image and it is a little bit
more warmer than i wanted and it just
wasn't working for me of course i did
play with the the colors a bit in the
lightroom and i was like get to this
more of this um
you know kind of toned them down a
little bit but i brought this more
natural organic look to it but it's just
the tonality that you get from the
sensor that really makes it even
interesting
and then this is shot at iso 3200 and as
we look uh you know behind him here you
can see the grain here it's not
distracting in any way as a matter of
fact it looks more fill mask but some
people don't want any grain anyway
with
you know a little bit of topaz de noise
i was able to clean that up and really
get a much cleaner image out of that
while still maintaining the detail in
the face so um i just started using this
software mind you other people use it
friends of mine use it do do wildlife
and birding and they swear by it and i
just tried it out and i can attest that
it really is
worth
a download to try it out to buy it or
not is up to you guys but it is
definitely worth trying it out but i
just again love the tonality and just
something that medium format gives you
especially in portraiture that is really
really unique um here's another shot of
andre and this is uh behind here and
look at all the detail that we're able
to capture on his back and he's trying
all this lint and everything else now
the final image that you have guys seen
in the review i've removed all that and
cleaned it up but i mean it's just quite
amazing how sharp this lens is but
what about chromatic aberration what
about purple or green fringing when it
comes to metallic objects let's take a
look at something right now here's um
these shocks that were on the wall here
at vicious cycle and again this is a
testament to how good this lens is
is i'm looking at these these shocks
here and they're chrome there's rust
there's all different tonalities and
colors and textures and i'm not seeing
anything that's distracting whatsoever
and yes this image has been edited let
me show the before edit
let's zoom in on that
look how control that is
i can't see anything honestly and here's
after edit
before edit
and after edit
and again
edge to edge
is sharp
very very impressive
uh let's look at this on the side of
this motorcycle real quick
i have this old honda here that's been
converted to a sort of a a chopper of
sorts gotta customize have some fun with
it but again look at this area right
here uh it's just beautiful i mean yeah
it's rust there's texture to it but if
you see how well the colors and the
tonality that just comes alive from the
sensor and the lens
and how much depth there is to this it
really is something to see
this is before edit and here's after
edit before editing after it now and
it's our personal preference you may
like or dislike what i'm doing but it is
something to take note of on it just uh
in terms of its texture
and also here's a tank that andre was
working on i think he's just finished it
but uh he just added these skulls on to
it here and he was just you know
brushing it up here on this area but
look at the
texture and the detail on this
um this is an iso 3200 mind you and it
is absolutely
beautiful at iso 3200 in terms of this
detail so again something to really take
note of in terms of performance of this
uh
this camera and this lens and here's one
last shot i want to show you guys this
is of this red harley-davidson v-raw
tank that he painted recently this is
deep cherry red and when i saw it in
person it just it just stood out to me
the tonality the depth to it and you
know yes with full frame cameras you can
capture some of this but that's where
medium format comes into play that's why
a lot of people still use medium format
for product photography to get that
tonality those colors that 16-bit color
you know that that dynamic range that
you get you see from the light to the
dark it's just that graduation it's
beautiful now this has been edited
slightly but
not much to mind you i mean most of this
was done with um spot metering and auto
exposure lock to kind of capture what i
was seeing with my eye because sometimes
if you just let the camera do everything
itself it can overexpose certain things
that underexpose other things so
something you don't want to do and then
you have end up spending more time in
photoshop or lightroom or focus or
capture one trying to fix that so if you
meter correctly
you will get some beautiful images with
really rich colors
anyway now let's go back to vicious
cycles and we will wrap up this video
with my final thoughts
in the right hands this is a very
powerful tool this lens as i mentioned
earlier on in this review and i think it
kind of
solidified it when you saw the images in
lightroom that
is probably one of the best
zooms in terms of image quality i've
ever used to date
um but the overall my thoughts on the
camera is that it is beautiful it is
this is a camera that you're not buying
as your everyday camera
this might be your secondary camera this
might be your
the camera that you take out on the
weekends if you're going to go traveling
and you want to capture
street images or portraits or you want
to just do something out of the norm but
you want a camera that speaks to you
this 907x will be that camera can you
use it for professional work yes 100
this is really meant to be on a tripod a
lot of the times especially going to be
doing a product photography or
commercial work but you can run a gun
with this you can go out there but
you're just gonna have to slow down
so big shout out to klez distribution
for providing the camera the accessories
thank you guys very much to vicious
cycles painful industries matt and andre
for allowing us to come into your home
and to photograph your work and these
iron horses
man it's a great place isn't it zacky
yeah yeah we could stay here all day
sweat a little bit but it's all worth it
anyway guys thanks so much for watching
like this video if it speaks to you
subscribe to the channel share this
video be safe out there and we'll chat
to you soon take care
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]